i'm here today to speak with I think
it's 400 students from LAUSD media
literacy program and I think it is great
for the Academy to do kind of brings
people that may have an interest and may
not have an interest or not know that
they have an interest to find a passion
before or if they have a passion to get
some insight on how they can sue pursue
it or an angle of how they can get into
the business or maybe why they don't
want to be in so it's I think it's a
great thing it was you know i'm here
today to talk about social network you
know it's an audience the kind of you
know basically up the generation that
was featured in the dome a little bit
younger but i look at social network is
a really inspirational story of someone
who built something there were so many
different takeaways from the movie it
was like a Shalon and it was mostly a
generational divide you know an older
generation saw a cautionary tale about
technology replacing humanity while the
younger generation people were here
today saw Mark Zuckerberg is a rock star
he kind of stuck it to the system and
did things his own way and both are
perfectly about and it speaks to this
generation as opposed to my parents my
grandparents that won't understand
Facebook this generation understands
that understands being in mind however
it's a classic tale and it's a tell that
is timeless but something that they can
no I think it's really important and I
mean a thing to do is bring this movie
for young people because all the movies
that are a lot of composition a
friendship face of you know enormous
pressure and hopefully success it's also
about building something when you're
young and have a vision executing not
waiting for an older generation to open
the door for right so that's why I think
you know the movie is really relevant